the Joe Rogan experience oh yeah what
could be next if we didn't see scooters
coming we didn't see Hoover coming what
would be the next what do we what do we
need what do we need you need protection
from the ocean the oceans gonna rise up
and take us it's good we're mounting the
ice caps gonna [ __ ] we're gonna have
to move to Tucson boats they're making
more subways here right now we'll use
those for the 2090 yeah we're gonna
throw our [ __ ] down those tubes like I
wonder man I mean there was some [ __ ]
that I was reading today about the ice
caps melting at an accelerated rate it's
always it's never good news yeah
whenever that it's like ice cap melting
news like hey we just found out we
actually have more ice than we thought
we're good all right don't worry about
it does that mean Vegas can get water
now no Vegas gets their water figure
they figured out there's so much money
in Vegas they just steal it where do
they get it you're from a hole in the
ground no idea is there a well out there
all I know they got good water pressure
and every Hotel I've ever been in it's
wonderful yeah look that's a human
ingenuity and they're building more [ __ ]
yeah and if the ice caps do melt it'll
just bring it closer to Vegas all right
Vegas to use it yeah the water will be
like real close yeah I mean we just move
inside to the middle like this is what
people have been doing forever this idea
that you're supposed to be able to keep
your [ __ ] house on the water in Santa
Monica nice and crazy decided build a
house where the beach is your front yard
that is so nuts you think those cliffs
were always there it was different
decades before so I keep on thinking
it's gonna be like that all the time
yeah if you buy like a seaside house in
like Marina del Rey or someone really
nice you're getting making a gamble like
over the next I'm only gonna be alive
for 40 more years right over those years
I'm gonna let's let's hope all right
that this water stays over there exactly
stays put
let's hope mother nature yeah there's
what I want it to do
yeah I just I'm gonna spend seven
million dollars in this [ __ ] house
with literally no backyard it's just
ocean and I'm
I hope it stays like yeah I just can't
wait till my crib becomes beachfront
property and then I could sell it
I've rented a beach house a couple of
years ago when my kitchen I was getting
my kitchen fixed and we rented this
house in Malibu on the water it was
beautiful man cuz you would wake up he
eat breakfast damn just be sitting there
staring out over the water and the water
would literally come almost underneath
the balcony so it looked like you were
sitting in water like you were floating
in while you're on a boat I was like wow
this is so beautiful it so makes you
feel so good yeah it does be by the
ocean but what a gamble yeah even though
it's the that's like you sound like
that's the ultimate infinity pool yeah
you know I'm saying quick yeah I don't
mind like la jolla you have the condo
right by the beach and then and you go
to sleep at night you could hear the
ocean your way huh yeah but then I'd be
like what if it's this is the night this
is the night where your noms in here
just takes the building down and rushes
it out there mountains I mean that's
happened so many times in history yeah
all it takes is a earthquake or an
asteroid hits the ocean oh yeah oh my
god if an asteroid hit the ocean we
wouldn't even be safe here
we wouldn't be safe we probably wouldn't
be safe in Arizona it would go deep in
Arizona asteroid hit the [ __ ] ocean
just outside of Malibu mmm just a big
one everybody in the Midwest be laughs
and they'd be laughing I'd say we had
the best property all the time yeah so
we had to duck hurricanes mm-hmm they
have the scary [ __ ] I think tornadoes
are the scary [ __ ] those things are so
random and they happen every year right
every year it's not like earthquakes
happen every year a hurricane you can
track you know it's coming you can
prepare you could just leave a tornado
it's just like did you show up hey man
I'm here yeah yeah that's the scariest
yeah but that's just something that
people deal with when they ec they wipe
out entire towns yeah wipe they take
towns off the map I feel like they just
all
aim for these small towns well I think
it has to do with the with agriculture
if I'm right I think it has to do with
like flat areas and the type of weather
that they have and I don't think they
take place in areas where there's a lot
of trees and forests mmm is that true
it's more like they don't really happen
in cities right as the heat structure
and it creates like a before the
pressure air pressure starts it's a hot
cold air pressure system that kind of
starts worse so because of the
artificial concrete yeah all those stuff
that's why tornadoes almost protect
above it does happen in cities from time
to time we're like on the outskirts but
like it's very rare to see one roll
through a downtown but does one ever go
to like Colorado
yeah I'm looking one up right here so as
you're saying trees I got video of one
like just ripping trees up in Texas so
like mmm but it does mostly - for sure
on flat land Texas azzam yeah yeah well
Texas Texas is a lot of crazy wind it's
so close to Oklahoma Oklahoma is like
Tornado Alley no I swear around there
there was one that was on TV that was
mad it was hitting this area where they
had these oil trucks and it was carrying
these semi trucks in the air I don't
know if there were oil trucks there's
semis like you can't like it's you know
like a 16-wheeler like [ __ ] truck in
like that it was flying in a circle in
the sky like a [ __ ] newspaper you
know a page from a newspaper gets caught
in the wind I was flying around this
this [ __ ] tornado was carrying trucks
like that hmm that's nicely new stuff
yeah but there's a video of that's it
right there that's the video this is a
video what you see look at this y-you
see the trucks as they get closer you
can see inside the [ __ ] thing that is
a truck flying in a circle if this is
the same video I don't know if that's it
no that's that's the same laughter lands
I mean that might not have even been it
but it was one where there was probably
so many [ __ ] tornado vision yes but
it was one where these trucks were
literally flying around in a circle like
it was carrying this gigantic semi and
just floating it in the air like a paper
airplane was it from twister though was
it some fake foot no no no it was real
it was real some news footage from
television it seems like then it's hard
to catch that because all these are just
already on the ground yeah no it wasn't
from a distance but there was some news
footage anyway
[Applause]